and i think she sees putin is sloppy i
think that he's he's looking at how
putin did this and he's looking that
putin made mistakes but the way
president xi is looking at this is
he's very much paying attention to every
country that's giving ukraine arms he's
paying attention to every company that's
no longer doing business with russia
he's watching what's happening at the un
he's watching how the world is isolating
russia and he's not saying no i'm not
going to do this he's saying okay when i
do this i'm going to have to do it
differently and so it again
we can't take our eyes off of china
because china is going to be next what
we need to do is learn the lessons of
russia and see what happens when
division comes in
which is what happened with us and our
allies when we look distracted it opens
a door for these thugs to do
um you know the devil's work and that's
exactly what they're doing
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former united states ambassador to
the united nations the former governor
of south carolina and someone who knows
a little something about international
relations ambassador nikki haley welcome
back to the reuben report thanks so much
great to be with you dave
well i'm glad to have you this week
because i've been telling my audience
for the last 10 days or so that it's
extremely hard right now to figure out
exactly what's going on in ukraine and
russia and of course kamala harris did
tell us that ukraine's small russia big
but i want to see if we can give a
little more thoughtful analysis to that
if possible so first could you just give
us
sort of a russia ukraine 101 a little
bit of the history some of the
geopolitics what got us to this moment
and then we'll go from there
well i think what got us to the moment
is we all know that the soviet union
fell and when it fell you know um russia
apparently had borders and ukraine had
freedom and democracy and what has
happened is putin has decided he's just
going to ignore history he's going to
recreate it and in his mind he thinks
that it needs to go back to the soviet
union and so he believes that ukraine is
part of russia it's part of the soviet
empire and he's only taking what is
rightfully theirs
ukraine on the other hand is a
flourishing democracy
where people appreciate freedom it was
knocking on putin's doorstep he was
worried that russians were going to see
the freedom that ukraine's the
ukrainians had and he didn't want that
to happen the lesson in all of this dave
is
that when a an evil dictator
thug says they're going to do something
we need to believe them putin said he
was going to take ukraine and he is
china said they were going to take hong
kong and they did putin says that he's
next going for poland and the baltics we
should believe it china says they're
going to get taiwan that's going to
happen iran says they're going to
destroy israel we need to start
understanding that when tyrants say
something we should believe them get in
front of it so that we don't see this
kind of bloodshed that's happening
because what's happening now is is
nothing short of a tragedy
is this one of the things that we
discussed in our original interview say
six or eight months ago where
if we don't if the united states does
not lead does not say hey we have red
lines that you can't cross
say there are things that you cannot do
if we don't do it that the world just
kind of goes to hell in the handbasket
it doesn't mean we do everything right
all the time but pretty much without us
nato doesn't function other countries
don't sort of stand up for what's right
yeah i think it was very clear to me at
the united nations that um whether
countries like the us or not they want
us to lead they would much rather follow
the united states and follow china or
russia any day of the week and you know
what i saw is when we speak the world
listens when we act the world follows
who we are the world wants to be and so
it doesn't mean we have to go to war but
it means that we need to speak and speak
loudly and we need to make sure we do it
in the name of freedom and we do it in
the name of peace and what we need to be
saying loudly now is
you know europeans thought that if they
were nice to russia that russia would
leave them alone and what you find out
is when you sleep with the devil the
devil owns you europeans became 40
percent dependent on russia on russian
oil russia is a one industry country
their whole livelihoods is surrounded by
energy and the energy industry and so
what europe has to do now is they have
to become
independent of russian oil poland and
lithuania have already done that they're
getting theirs from australia
the united states should not be taking
russian oil we could open up the
keystone pipeline and that would take up
the oil that we're getting from them but
also we need to double down on fracking
we need to export liquefied natural gas
we need to really start to understand
this is a national security issue
because while a lot of people think this
is just ukraine
a million people have migrated out of
ukraine into all of those european
countries especially poland right now
the entire european region is going to
be disrupted and we're all going to feel
that and so
this is about being smart and realizing
where we are and the fact that we need
to be doing something if you see the
death that's happening in the streets of
ukraine
um don't think that's over there that
very well could be us that's not saying
you know anytime there is a free
democracy there's a tyrant ready to take
it um we've seen that with israel for a
long time you're now seeing that with
ukraine you're gonna see it with taiwan
the united states has to figure out what
they want to be when they lead and i
think we are always right when we lead
on the side of freedom so you briefly
mentioned sanctions there i'm sure you
saw the clips last week where jan saki
basically was saying you know we have
these incredible sanctions sanctions
like you've never seen before and then
just hours later i think it was our
deputy energy secretary who said oh but
it won't affect the energy sector of
russia's economy i mean do you sense
that the people that are in charge right
now from biden to the spokesman to the
rest of them that they have a sense of
really what's going on here i mean
they're running scared
they're running scared either you're
going to be tough on putin or you're not
the only way to be tough on putin is to
sanction the energy companies
president zielinski of ukraine is
begging for it he's begging for things
and you know are we okay allowing people
to die in the streets of ukraine because
we're worried that russia will get mad
if we sanction their energy sector no we
should be teaching russia a lesson by
sanctioning their energy companies we
should be pulling them out of the
international banking system we should
be sending um arms to ukraine so they
can defend themselves and protect
themselves you know they desperately
need anti-air anti-tank javelin and
stinger missiles we should be sending
those over you know
zielinski has said look you know send us
planes send us tanks send us anything
and you know the united states if we
stepped up and did it the rest of the
world would step up and do it 20
countries now have provided ukraine with
all sorts of military equipment and
things that they need but i'm worried
it's going to be too little too late
what would you say to the people who
make the argument that okay so you do
everything you can on sanctions we arm
the ukrainians we get some real alliance
worldwide alliance against putin
but this guy does have nukes we there's
questions about you know what his real
motives are and mental health and all of
that stuff that that if we do basically
what you're laying out there that we
then
we just don't know what's at the end of
the road of that if you pin this guy or
if you paint him into a corner america's
never been scared we can't be scared now
what you do is you fight evil wherever
it exists we need strength right now if
he's going to do something he's going to
do it regardless the best thing we can
do is continue to isolate
isolate him in the eyes of the world and
continue to make sure that we have all
of our allied partners together i mean
the thing that bothers me the most is
where are the arab countries they
haven't said a word through all this
this is an oil war they should
absolutely be saying something you know
why they're not saying anything is they
don't trust that america will lead and
they don't trust that putin will fail
and so the best thing the united states
could do is step up and lead and kick
putin where it hurts
might he use nukes yes but the bigger
question is
ukraine had nuclear production
and there was a treaty that was done
with us russia and ukraine where ukraine
gave up all of their nukes they were the
third largest holder of nuclear arms
gave up all of their nukes in the name
of being free in the name of being
independent what does this say to
countries like iran
north korea those that were saying they
have to denuclearize why would they give
up their arms now when they know that
they really don't get the protections
they say they're going to get so what
you're going to see is the world is
going to start going back to the nuclear
arms you're going to start beefing up
because they're worried about when it's
going to happen to them
did ukraine just not understand full
geopolitics and giving up nukes i mean
at the end of the day that you have to
be uh responsible for your own security
even if everything was right in the u.s
and and the world was really trying to
do the best they could that at the end
of the day it still is about you
defending yourself
well you know i think ukraine tried to
do the right thing you know what they
did was in the name of peace
they said okay we won't produce we'll
give ours up
but history will now look back and i
think ukrainians are probably looking
back going should we have done that and
i think now that you know the rest of
the world's going to look at that and
that's why you're going to see
um all the talks about you know
denuclearizing are going to be on pause
for a good while
so you know i'm with you on the you sort
of have to have peace through strength
but there i do also have a uh a strong
libertarian side and part of me right
now and i'm hearing this from my
audience also people are just kind of
like you know we're so screwed up in
this country right now
all the woke stuff and critical race
theory and the border and inflation
and supply chain and of course we can
relate some of that back to the energy
which gets us to russia but that there's
just so many problems right now it's
like can't someone else do something
right now and i am somewhat sympathetic
to that even hearing the arguments like
there is part of me that's just like
maybe
there's just too much to chew up right
now especially because i just don't have
faith in our leaders right now if we had
leaders that i had faith in maybe i
would feel a little bit differently
well you know i've always had a
libertarian streak to me too and i think
that you know government needs to stay
out of a lot of things and we would be
much better off but what i will tell you
is we always have to fight for freedom
and the reason we fight for freedom is
because it could you know the threats
could end up on our doorstep why should
you care about ukraine you should care
about ukraine because this was a country
that all they were doing was mining
their own business they were trying to
be free and what you've got is you've
got tyrants around the world i saw this
at the united nations russia and china
started to get together not because they
like each other not because they trust
each other but because the one unifying
thing for both of them is they want to
destroy the west they want to destroy
democracy they want to destroy freedom
and they're going to do whatever they
can to do that the reason you should
care about ukraine is because if russia
gets away with this taiwan is next
and china will take taiwan it's not if
it's when and when they do taiwan
produces you know half of the the world
semiconductor chips so for all of your
viewers if you like your phone if you
like your computer if you like your car
all these things that we now
electronically can't live without
china would literally own us we would be
in the same situation situation that
europe is with russia on the dependency
of of energy we would be in that same
dependency with china and china would
not be near as kind as russia i can
promise you that they're stronger
they're sleeker they're smarter and
they're more determined than ever
to ruin the west and so these are all
places we have to care about because if
if it's another country it could be us
and we're not saying go to war i'll be
the first one to say
as a wife of a combat veteran that's a
last resort what i am saying is use the
power of our voice for good
use the fact that we do have military
arms that we can send for good use the
fact that we can help get our allies
together to become less dependent on
russia so they don't put all of us in a
bad situation so that we can really get
more alliances together that's all for
good that's not you know that's not
going to war that's not getting
government involved that's saying we're
going to protect freedom and we have to
protect freedom wherever it reigns
how much of this do you blame on the
biden administration i mean you were uh
at the u.n under president trump you
know it's not that we had perfect world
peace obviously but putin was quiet when
it came to ukraine he did some stuff
crimea under obama uh but there was
certainly the feeling that if he did
something
under trump who obviously was like well
what would trump do so he didn't do any
you know so putin didn't make a move how
much of this do you blame on on biden
you mentioned keystone pipeline i mean
we're reliant on the bad guys this is a
problem
biden is has really really done this to
all of us and i will tell you this never
would have happened under president
trump um and it was because president
trump
really kind of laid it out there for all
the tyrants out there but president
trump did something that russia
absolutely disliked he built up our
military which russia never wanted us to
do he made sure we were energy
independent which russia didn't like and
he made sure that he
would not allow nordstrom 2 to go
through which was going to be a big
revenue source
for russia but what's happened since
then president biden
now comes into office
he allows afghanistan to fall but not
only did afghanistan fall what they saw
was the united states left bagram air
force base in the middle of the night
without telling the allies who stood
shoulder to shoulder with us for two
decades without telling them that we
were doing it
big signal to our enemies big signal to
our elements then you go forward and he
goes and waves nordstrom too a gift to
putin at a time that he needed it then
you add on to that biden's falling all
over himself to get into the iran deal
i mean that the weakness of that when
iran wouldn't even let the us in the
room biden's begging to get back into a
deal with the number one state sponsor
of terror and then finally you see biden
speak
and what does he say he says well if
it's a minor incursion we'll do one
thing if it's an invasion we'll do
another
those were all green lights for putin
putin knew that never again would we
have a weak president like this in
america and it's the same thing
president xi sees in china they see it
they know there's an opportunity putin
chose to move on it it never would have
happened under president trump because
there was never any weakness there was
deterrence under president trump do you
think putin's a little surprised that it
seems like the whole world has rallied
around this i mean you know they're
talking about kicking them off the swift
system and the sanctioning of the
oligarchs and all of this stuff i i
don't know that it's going to work
exactly but do you think he's a little
surprised how quickly things came to be
although they did russia did veto their
security council members so they vetoed
the un security council resolution which
is sort of hilarious i suppose in a
depressing sense
i think he's completely taken aback i
mean i don't think that he thought that
um
you know that he was going to see this
much resistance i don't think he thought
that president zielinski would become
this much of a hero
i don't think he knew the courage and
inspiration
um that the ukrainian people would be to
the world and so you know what you've
got as ukrainians picking up knives from
their kitchens if they have to they're
you know standing up in front of tanks
they're
you know picking up guns from anywhere
and they're fighting back for their
freedom and fighting back to their
country we should take a lesson from
them on how much they are doing to
protect being free how precious being
free actually is and so i think putin's
absolutely taken back and i think she
sees putin is sloppy i think that he's
he's looking at how putin did this and
he's looking at putin made mistakes but
the way president xi is looking at this
is
he's very much paying attention to every
country that's giving ukraine arms he's
paying attention to every company that's
no longer doing business with russia
he's watching what's happening at the un
he's watching how the world is isolating
russia and he's not saying no i'm not
going to do this he's saying okay when i
do this i'm going to have to do it
differently and so it again
we can't take our eyes off of china
because china is going to be next what
we need to do is learn the lessons of
russia and see what happens when
division comes in
which is what happened with us and our
allies when we look distracted it opens
a door for these thugs to do
um you know the devil's work and that's
exactly what they're doing
so if you were still the ambassador at
the un right now if you were the u.s
ambassador at the u.n and you were
sitting apart from sitting across the
table from your russian counterpart
right now what would you be saying to
him
like how do we get putin to turn back
like what what do you think his off-ramp
is what would you be offering them to
say hey okay this thing got messy for
two weeks but let's let's back up now
well first of all dave i would be
railing at the united nations right now
i would have been railing every single
day
to get some attention towards ukraine
before this conflict happened but also
to kind of rally the world into not just
saying you're with ukraine but actually
doing something about it and having them
act and the first group that needs to
act in the europeans it's their region
they need to really step up did we do
anything did we do anything at the u.n i
mean this was like a slow-motion war for
three weeks where biden kept saying oh
it's gonna happen maybe it'll happen
tomorrow three days i mean were we doing
anything at the un oh yes absolutely um
what america was doing at the un was um
they got back into the u.n human rights
council you know and now they're sitting
on that human rights council shoulder
shoulder with russia and china who um
russia is now committing war crimes so
by neither needs to to kick russia out
of the human rights council or he needs
to get off himself
america was active at the u.n in in
dealing with this iran deal can you
imagine now that you're going to go in a
room and negotiate with china and russia
on you know how to stop iran from
producing nuclear weapons that's that's
a joke and it would it's a fireable
offense if biden continues to try and
get into this iran deal and so yeah they
were doing things they were doing all
the wrong things and what they should
have been doing was rallying the troops
what they should have been doing was
tough love to the europeans saying stop
this and you know one of the things i
did was i was constantly beating up
germany for nordstrom 2. and you know
and we were constantly saying this can't
happen that never should have been
allowed to happen um this year so there
were a lot of things done it just were
all the wrong things
so when
they have a resolution at the u.n and
one of the countries that's doing the
invading has veto power is it all just
theater i mean at the end like is it
just sort of ridiculous theater because
russia vetoed the resolution about
russia you can't blame them for doing
that so the interesting thing is yes
russia vetoed the resolution in the
security council um but what they were
able to do that russia couldn't do
anything about was they took it to the
general assembly you know the 193
countries and what happened was you know
basically the world condemned russia
there were only five countries on the
side of russia russia included but
russia stood there with syria and north
korea those are not friends you want to
be sitting on the corner with and that's
who they were and so yeah they did that
but at the end of the day what does a
resolution do right so
yes it's you know you're you're
condemning you're telling russia you're
bad you got to stop but it's not doing
anything and so you know there goes to
my um frustration with the united
nations is you know saying something and
acting that's great now what you know
now we get it
so so what does a a sane resolution of
this situation look like to you i mean
is this something that we're just going
to be sort of slowly in for a long time
is there something that we can do to
give putin that off ramp so that he
doesn't have to escalate what what is a
what does an actual out of this look
like well i think look at the
environment right so you've got
ukrainians um taking to the streets to
defend themselves you've got russians
it's pretty ironic that you've got
thousands of russians taking to the
streets of russia protesting putin um
extremely courageous because they know
that they'll be killed they know that
they'll be jailed for doing that um
you've got you know the europeans really
stepping up at a time to help ukraine i
think that you're going to see russia is
going to continue to take
uh ukraine by force um i think they're
going to kind of sit on the barrier for
a while um
and try and see how much progress they
can make but at the end of the day
putin's going to try and put one of his
own lackeys in government um you know in
ukraine but the ukrainian people aren't
going to go for that i mean i think
you've seen the spirit of the ukrainian
people they're not ever going to go for
that so putin's got to figure this out
you know he's already become a pariah in
the world he's isolating himself so he's
already very paranoid um i think he's
worried about being eliminated himself
we know that he's trying to eliminate
zielinski um so you know i think this
isn't gonna
be done in a couple of days the sad part
is the media is going to get tired of
raised the media is not going to have
constant ukraine shots and everybody
else is going to go back to their
business but the bloodshed's not going
to stop and i think this is going to
last a while
yeah i'm glad you mentioned the media
part of this because i feel that it's my
job to just sort of translate some of
this stuff to my audience and bring on
people like you who are the experts in
this so that they can get an honest
assessment of this one of the things
that i'm really struggling with right
now is who to trust you know i've lost
such trust in our corporate press that
you know it's very hard for me to pick
up the new york times that i feel lies
about so many things and say oh but this
is the thing they're telling the truth
on how do you i mean is it just from
talking to other ambassadors and talking
to people on the ground how do you get
news that makes sense to you i i read a
lot and i read a lot of different
sources and i do i've been in
conversations with my um counterpart at
the united nations from ukraine who's
now back in ukraine um you know we we're
talking to people who have families on
the ground in russia you know you just
you read as much as you can and you take
all the opinions out of it that's the
key is you know the media wants to tell
you what to think you don't need to know
what to think you need to know the facts
and then you put together what you think
on your own and so you know you can't
read too much but the media at this
point i will say the media at least
they're covering ukraine in what is a
fair way they're not trying to you know
rosie up on on putin they're they're
calling him the thug that he is they're
showing the bloodshed that's happening
they're they're highlighting zielinski
and the brave um people of ukraine and i
think that's what we need to see but you
know the media hasn't been
an outlet to trust for a very long time
do you think that if it was the guy that
you worked for president trump and this
was happening right now that the media
would be treating this the same i mean
it seems fairly obvious to me that the
media would be everything would be at
the footsteps of america right now and
this is what trump brought upon us i
mean you can actually see them doing
some of that blaming trump for this sake
you know you probably saw that line the
other day where she said there's a
pattern here of uh of putin invading
ukraine uh she forgot that the thing
that broke the pattern was the four
years under trump
you know it's interesting because i've
i've always told everybody you know the
four years that president trump had he
never got an ounce of peace or
one bit of credit through all four years
he was hammered every day all day and he
didn't have afghanistan he didn't have
the ukraine mess he didn't have
inflation like this he didn't have the
crime in the streets he didn't have all
that and they still beat up on him and
then you know to go have them hail by
the state of the union speech um as this
amazing unifier you know it wasn't that
all it was was a lot of republican
talking points saying you know we've got
to get rid of crime on the streets we've
got to put kids back in school we have
to choose freedom over tyranny you know
we've got to fund the police well guess
what we've been saying that this entire
year that biden's been in office and now
he's saying it but you he didn't offer
one solution not one solution and you
know the only solution dave is to win
the races in 2022 we've got to take back
the house we've got to take back the
senate we've got 36 governors races and
if you ever saw um the the importance of
a governor you know you saw it during
covet and you saw some fantastic
republican governors go and protect
their people and i think that we've got
to really make sure that we put a stop
to all of this progressive
extremism that we're seeing come out of
the left and you know stop biden and try
and you know say a prayer along the way
because it's going to be a long three
years
not only do i know it but as you know
i'm living it because i am in the free
state of florida right now not at my
home in cali anymore uh we only have a
couple minutes left uh but let's just go
with the the political part of this for
just a bit does it drive you crazy like
when you watch the state of the union
and biden basically starts repeating the
things that republicans conservatives
whatever have been saying for years oh
now we have to fund the police we have
to get kids back in school et cetera
does it drive you nuts that that they
can always get away with it that's where
i'm really hung up at the moment like
they're getting away with it and i think
by october they're going to have people
believing that it was republicans who
wanted lockdowns and republicans who
wanted mandates and republicans who
wanted to defund the police et cetera et
cetera they're not going to get away
with it dave
the american right
the american public is too smart the
american people are too smart i was
campaigning for glenn yonkin in virginia
i was campaigning for jack chitarelli in
new jersey and we only lost that race by
one percentage point and i'm telling you
the frustration on the ground in
virginia was no different than the
frustration on the ground in new jersey
and what you saw were
you saw independents and conservative
democrats say we've had enough they were
tired of what was happening to their
kids in schools they're tired of seeing
all these mandates they were tired of
seeing the crime in their streets and
they're each you know every family is
paying more than 250 more a month that's
a lot so no i don't think the american
people will fall for this and i think
they'll show it um when we come november
in 2022 and we went all these races back
all right ambassador i only win that
means we have to prove we deserve to be
there when we get there
yeah well absolutely so i only have one
more question for you it's the question
you definitely don't want but because
i'm on the record as saying that i want
desantis to stay here in florida because
i believe that those those governorships
are so important uh there is a
presidential election after the other
thing i kind of asked you last time i
mean how you feeling obviously you're
not thrilled with worldwide leadership
at the moment and there's going to be a
really wide-ranging crop whoever is in
it i'm excited for the republican crop
because i do sense it's going to be a
lot of new fresh blood and there'll be a
sort of wide variety of voices are you
thinking about it at all
well i think that there is no 24 if we
don't win in 2022 but i i don't think i
have to make a decision until the first
part of 23.
i can tell you i've never lost a race
i'm not going to start now um so if
there's a place for me then we'll move
if there's not i'm going to fight for
america for as long as i can um and and
make sure that we do whatever we need to
the beauty of it is is the republican
bench is strong we've got a lot of
talent um on our bench the democrat
bench not so much
the current situation with them ain't so
great either uh ambassador haley i
appreciate you taking the time and uh
hopefully we can do this in person
sometime soon thanks so much dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell